welcome to the show everybody much to
cover today we'll begin with a prominent
socialist on YouTube and social media a
guy who regularly rails against the rich
really doesn't like rich people well um
it says they have no credibility to
speak on on anything and we shouldn't
listen to them well you'll never guess
where this is going
big big twist ending turns out the guy
himself is extremely wealthy his family
owns multiple mansions on and on and on
so we'll talk about that there seems to
be a theme here this seems to be a trend
where you've got these prominent
socialists who end up being rich why is
that we'll talk about it also five
headlines including
an update on the ongoing civil war over
toilet paper that is happening in the
aisles of our supermarket spurred on by
the coronavirus why is it that everybody
is rushing to the store to get toilet
paper because of the coronavirus well
we'll try to figure that out as well and
a coronavirus related daily cancellation
that would get to finally some of your
emails Pat writes in to tell me why I'm
wrong about abortion so he believes he's
got a great argument they'll debunk
everything I say about the subject and
we'll get to that we'll read it we'll
see if if he succeeds or not by the way
I'd be remiss if I didn't take a moment
and wish you a belated happy
International Women's Day
International Women's Day was was
yesterday I hope you celebrated it uh
you know as you know I believe in
celebrating women I'm something of a
reputed feminist and it should it's just
something I believe in it's as simple as
that celebrating women celebrating
progress it's it's something that's
important to me and so I went up to my
wife in honor of the holiday and I said
listen to it's it's International
Women's Day and I want you to really
enjoy it so I'm gonna let you make me
whatever you want for dinner it's up to
you go crazy with it and and then I said
you can even make a little for yourself
too you can even have you can even have
half a half a portion if you want and
the look in her in her eyes was well it
just made it all worth it I have to say
and that's what supporting women is all
about folks so again I hope you had a
great day there before we get to the
rich
socialist not Bernie Sanders but the
other if so no not-not-not Michael Moore
the other the other other rich socialist
before we get to that speaking of me
being a sexist bigot I'll be speaking at
the University of Maryland tonight I
wanted to mention I'll be giving my talk
on the left's war on reality focusing
especially on their assaults on life
marriage and gender well maybe I don't
know we've got Pat's email on abortion
so maybe he'll convince me otherwise
I'll have to take the life part out of
it we'll see but that's probably what
the talk is gonna be out be about and it
turns out that some of the students
don't want me there which is really
surprising because I'm such a lovable
guy I don't know why anybody wouldn't
like me and there's this poster going
around that was put up on campus it says
fascist bigots out of Maryland stand
with lgbtq+ um rosette sir I can't even
read the University of Maryland students
against bigotry and hatred on their
campus first of all you need her for a
poster you need much better font than
this it's hard to read at least for me
I'm also half blind Matt Walsh of Daley
wire speaking at stamps Student Union
then it offers a quote for me it says if
there is trans acceptance in society
Western civilization is over I don't
think that's a direct quote that's I
don't think I said that exactly help us
show opposition to Walsh's dangerous
rhetoric meet at the front entrance at
6:00 okay so there you go all I wanted
to say about this is um I find it a
little bit hurtful because you know
calling me a fascist bigot I think it's
out of bounds I have made it very clear
I am a theocratic fascist bigot so
that's the particular flavor of
oppression and tyranny that I personally
support and I would appreciate it if you
would respect my self-identification
that's all I'm gonna say about that
anyway I'll be there at 7:00 tonight so
hopefully I'll see you there one other
note at the top here before we get into
before we get into everything else and
this is from LegalZoom look
you don't need to go to law school in
order to get good legal advice I know
that when it comes to it kind of feels
like if you if you've got an issue you
need legal advice you need you need to
have gone to law school yourself in
order to sort through everything but
that's not the case over the past 19
years Legal Zoom has helped more than 2
million Americans start their businesses
by incorporating forming an LLC and more
they're going to help you navigate
through that very seemingly daunting
process and they're gonna give you all
the information that you need and
they're gonna put it right at your
fingertips make it very easy for you but
even after your business is set up Legal
Zoom can still help you with a lot more
because of course anyone who's a
business owner you know that there's
ongoing need for for legal advice
especially with all the red tape and
everything you deal with as a business
owner things like lease agreements
changing tax laws reviewing contracts
all that plays a part in running your
business and Legal Zoom is gonna help
you with that
these are precisely the kinds of costly
hurdles that could take time away from
you actually running your business don't
let that happen
legal zooms network of independent
attorneys and tax professionals can
provide advice to address these things
and much more than that and you'll never
get changed by charge by the hour that
is since Legal Zoom is not a law firm so
it's not going to cost you the same way
go to legalzoom.com today enter promo
code Walsh in the box at checkout for
special savings that's legalzoom.com
code Walsh Legal Zoom where life meets
legal ok Carlos Mazza maybe you've heard
of him maybe not he is well he's this
guy the long dark night of the end of
history has to be grasped as an enormous
opportunity the very oppressive
pervasiveness of capitalist realism
means that even glimmers of alternative
political and economic realities can
have a disproportionately great effect
the tiniest events can tear a hole in
the gray curtain of reaction which has
marked the horizon of possibility from a
situation in which nothing can happen
suddenly anything is possible
yes very smart very smart guy you can
tell he's smart because of the big words
that's how you know that's how you know
the smart people
actually he was he was quoting a book
there which makes him even smarter and
Mazda you may remember him from when he
was he was trying to deep platform
steven crowder a while back so he's that
same guy he's big in 2d platforming
people sort of his thing
part of his motto in fact his motto is
be gay do socialism D platform bigots
like I said the guy's a genius do
socialism cry you know you can't you
can't you can't put it any better way
than that he's also as it turns out a
filthy hypocrite there's a fascinating
piece in the New York Post from John
Levine Levine exposes maz's hypocrisy
and the price that he paid for it Levine
did is that he got suspended from
Twitter he's reporting on this Twitter
suspended him twice suspended him let
him back suspended him again and then
said that he could come back if he
deletes some of his reporting about
Carlos Meza which which he had to do so
he could come back and in this is this
is what happens the the leftist
hypocrites protect their own they circle
the wagons
now as Levine reports Mazza is not only
a socialist but he has taken he's taken
to publicly criticizing people for being
wealthy here he is attacking James
Carville for for being rich says just
found out James Carville who spends his
time lecturing Democrats for being too
far left lives in an absolutely obscene
four-story mansion and dear God can we
stop taking political advice from the
ultra-wealthy
you know he continues you really have to
respect this guy's grift constantly
dressing in normal clothes on TV to
feign relatability while living like
this
masterful con artist and another quote
another post quoted by levine he
apparently wrote we should treat gay
people the same way we treat straight
people eating them when they get too
rich so he's you know he's in he wants
to eat the rich he's into that meanwhile
Mads also fund raises from his followers
hits them up for cash calls them his
comrades the ones who donate to him
don't intrude to him through through
patreon all of this despite being
himself apparently
enormous ly wealthy reading now from the
post article says through his clan the
Millennial firebrand is connected to
multiple Florida mega mansions a 7 point
1 million dollar pad on the Upper West
Side
purchased purchase under an LLC and a
yacht by luxury boat maker Don Z
personally they're my favorite yacht
maker I've got a couple and that's if
you're going for a yacht definitely go
for the Don Z just my opinion
I says maz's mother Vivian Mazda was one
of his foes of one of the first
employees at ultimate software a Florida
based behemoth which now employs more
than 5,000 people starting in 1990 as an
office manager she ultimately rose to
become the group's chief people officer
in 2004 in addition to her day job
vivian masa has developed a very close
personal relationship with the company
founder scott share so close that an
independent assessment of the company in
2016 cited the relationship as a
corporate governance concern the report
said they believe the pair to be more
than just coworkers and have a familial
relationship the two later became
engaged and the couple has lived
together for years with share being a de
facto stepfather to carlos public
records show vivian scott carlos and
sister Isabel all registered to vote at
a five-bedroom eight bathroom waterfront
palace in Boca Raton Florida first of
all what do you need eight bathrooms for
talk about wasting water why would you
need more bathrooms and you have pee
they got twice as many bathrooms as
people each person gets two bathrooms
the property sold in 2018 for ten point
eight million dollars according to
Realty website Zillow share also
unloaded a four-bed four-bath home in
2015 may in 2015 in western Florida for
1.8 million just 1.8 million little
poultry little thing vivianne currently
resides full-time in a four point four
million dollar to bed three bath luxury
condo in Fort Lauderdale which she lists
as her primary residence according to a
20/20 report filed by LCH 23 LLC which
she controls the same LLC purchased a
7.1 million dollar condo on the Upper
West Side of Manhattan in November 2017
let's take a look at the mansion this is
the one I believe in Boca Raton so there
it is right there
pretty pretty pretty nice nicer than
Bernie's place so I bet there's a little
bit of a little bit of socialist
jealousy going on there the Socialists
are all about jealousy that's their
whole thing and it continues it's not
clear how much Vivian and Cher actively
support maz's lifestyle but evidence
suggests the family has been happy to
pitch in to help spread his socialist
message both Cher and Vivian Mazza are
listed as a as comrades at the end of
Carlos's most recent YouTube video and
the younger Madame self admitted in an
interview with Mel magazine that his
family was there to financially back him
if he needed it viv and Scott also have
pitched in on the rent for Carlos's chic
East Village pad just across from
Tompkins Square Park rents for about
three thousand a month according to the
post okay so there you have it
now if I were to attempt some kind of
long-distance psychotherapy here I would
say that maybe Carlos has some mommy and
daddy issues and so his eat the rich
stuff is really about his resentment for
his parents in fact I think there's a
lot of that in in there we've talked
about what's the reason why socialism
has become so popular with the younger
generation and there are many reasons
for it we've got into I think one issue
that does play a part is this mommy and
daddy issues I why is it that so many of
these young socialists are you know
they're college educated love them went
to nice colleges they don't come from
dirt poverty a lot of them they come
from upper-class society and they they
were raised by well-off baby boomers
probably a lot of them you know their
parents - parents are one probably
divorced both working full time they
were latchkey kids came home to empty
houses maybe they had a nanny that was
there and all the electronics that they
that they could ever want and they were
playing video games stuff but they did
you know they they felt emotionally
neglected see I told you I'm doing the
psychotherapy I think this is part of it
they felt emotionally neglected by their
rich parents growing up and now they're
taking that out on those pair
by saying let's eat the rich rich people
are evil what they really mean is my
parents are evil I don't like my parents
at the same time though they've got no
problem accepting help from their
parents in fact they demand it so
they're gonna take the money yes you
could pay my my my rent and you could
pay for my cell phone and everything
else but I still hate rich people so I
think there's part of it but generally
we find this with of course with many of
the prominent high-profile socialists
out there we find that socialism is a
grift
speaking of Griff's and in many ways
it's very similar to the snake oil
televangelists who get rich preaching
their own self-serving version of the
gospel carlos Mazza bernie sanders
michael moore these guys are they're
like the the Jim Baker's of socialist
politics Jim Baker by the way is a
televangelist
I've talked about him before he's he was
the one he was arrested for fraud went
to prison for it and then got out and
went went got right back into it got
right back into being a wolf in sheep's
clothing put the sheep's clothing right
back on dove right in has a big
following again is on TV right now he's
he's Hawking a liquid that he says can
cure the corona virus and you can buy it
for the low low price of $300 so that's
what these people are be they're like
Jim Baker accept of socialism they've
got their own calibrated self-serving
message of salvation that they sell
literally sell to the dazed and confused
and credulous masses and the only
difference I guess is while the snake
oil televangelists are preying off and
upon the elderly the snake oil
socialists are preying upon the young
and dumb
provides for once a great transition to
an ad I want to celebrate this moment my
first time that I get a seamless
transition I've already ruined it by
talking about it so there goes the
seamlessness of it time is running out
to get 25 percent off all daily wire
membership plans using coupon code never
socialist this is the last week we're
giving you this offer and I you know I'm
getting emotional just thinking of all
the people who aren't gonna get their
discount because they missed out on the
deal I why would you do that to yourself
why would you in these terrible trying
times add an extra burden onto you and
your family by not taking advantage of
this deal daily wire members get an
ad-free website experience access to all
of our live broadcasts and show labra
including the Matt Walsh show the full
three hours of the Ben Shapiro show
access to the mailbag you get all of
this okay you don't take us up on the
deal I don't know what to say you hate
yourself you hate us you hate America
how dare you along with all this of
course you get the magnificent
irreplaceable the singular leftist
here's tumblr and if you haven't already
download the daily wire apps you can get
all of our great content on the go again
that's 25% off the daily wire
memberships for all plans using coupon
code never socialists so head on over to
daily wire comm so I subscribed the deal
is ending this week so join now that's
daily wire calm slash subscribe alright
let's go to headlines number one Dwayne
Wade posted on Instagram last night
reintroducing his his his son as his
daughter his son at just 12 years old
recently transitioned quote-unquote into
a girl and by direct transition we mean
he remains a boy totally a boy in every
sense but he's pretending to be a girl
because he's confused the child is and
Dwayne and his Hollywood actress wife
are more than happy to foment and
encourage that confusion because it
helps them feel trendy and progressive
and and
with the times and that's what this is
about so here's the post says everyone
everyone allow her to reintroduce
herself her name is saya wait last night
was Zayas first red carpet and we
couldn't have been prouder of how she
handled the questions that were asked of
her
she has rumor emerged as one of the
young voices and faces for the lgbtq+
community okay again this is a boy in
every sense a boy very straightforward
only the boy is now wearing women's
pants it's a boy in women's pants that's
what this is nothing confusing here
there's no there's no scientific marvel
people say it's a complex issue you know
no it's not complex
there's nothing complex about this that
is a boy wearing women's pants and a
green jacket that's what that is and
it's it's in no way do the pants or
jacket make him a girl in no way in no
way does anything make him a girl or
could anything he's gonna be a boy
forever okay that is a scientific fact
now and his own confusion his own
feelings those don't make him a girl
either and if you think that confusion
and feelings is what makes somebody a
girl well then I would suggest that you
know you are a sexist and and and that's
something you need to think about in
International Women's week now the other
question is how is he a face and voice
for the LGBTQ community he's 12 years
old what makes him a face and voice for
anyone and why are you trying to put
your child forward at the age of 12 as
the face and voice for a whole community
of people they were this was a red
carpet for something called the truth
Awards by the way and that's the event
they were attending the truth Awards are
an awards show for LGBTQ people in the
arts so the kid just quote came out as
trans a few weeks ago already they're
bringing him to award shows and they've
got him on a red carpet and you're gonna
tell me this isn't about the parents
wanting
trendy I mean even if you think that a
12 year old can become a girl okay even
if you know absolutely nothing about
science even if you know less about
science than my six year old to do so
you think that a boy can become a girl
you should still agree that wouldn't win
a when a 12 year old is going through
this process you know bring him out to a
red carpet and traipse him in front of
cameras and start saying there
he's a merge she's quote-unquote she's
emerged as a was a quote she's she has
emerged as one of the young faces and
voices but what do mean emerge this is a
few weeks ago already he's a face and
voice for the algebra how so he's only
that because you're forcing him to be
that because you're putting him in front
of cameras what a what a what a shock
when you when you stick your kids in
front of cameras all of a sudden they
become a face and voice number two it
turns out that someone was infected with
the corona virus at CPAC lovely Ted Cruz
Ted Cruz and and Representative Paul
Gosar are going into voluntary self
quarantine they say because they
apparently interacted with this
individual a reasonable precaution as
the the the virus is thought to have as
much of as a 14-day incubation period so
CPAC was over a week ago so they're
going in for the remainder of the 14
days they say they have no symptoms just
precautions which is great
now if the virus is has a 14-day
incubation period and it's contagious
for that whole time then that obviously
is not great news and it would seem like
maybe your chances of getting the virus
may become might become greater than
your chances of not getting it
if that's the case fortunately according
to the CDC I was reading about this and
what they're saying is it looks like
right now a lot of this is tentative
because we still don't know a lot about
the virus but what they're saying is
they think it's possible for someone
that for number one for the virus to
incubate for 14 days and it
possible for someone to transmit the
virus when they're asymptomatic but
they're also saying that it's much more
likely that you'll contract it if you do
from someone who is showing symptoms and
from direct personal contact with them
as long as that remains the the by far
the primary way that the virus is a
spread that I would think that
containment is a real possibility but
when you start talking about 14 days
incubation contagious the whole time
that's where it gets a little bit a
little bit more unwieldy number three
and it may be early on but we've already
reached the fistfights over toilet paper
stage of the epidemic here's what that
looks like
toilet paper has become a hot commodity
in fact my wife went to the grocery
store yesterday not not panic buying but
we we actually just needed groceries
just for normal thing to go to the
grocery store which is what we do every
week but she went she said it was cheap
she tested it was like the apocalypse it
was entire shelves cleaned out very
difficult to find basic items especially
things for our kids which is concerning
so we so but here's here's what happens
now so we go to the store and we need
stuff for a kit we need toilet paper
also like everybody does at a civilized
society we also need wipes and diapers
and things for our kids but those things
are being scooped up and so now we have
to stock up on them too and we've got to
go and start it's not I wouldn't call it
panic buying we're not panicking but
we've got to do that too because we want
to make sure we have that available for
our kids if we need it and this is what
this is this is how panic works this is
how mass hysteria works it is
self-generating people are asking why is
everybody running out to the store for
toilet paper well everyone's running out
to the
or Bieber because everybody else is
running out to the store for toilet
paper and you don't want to be the one
left without a toilet paper and so
that's what happens it there's not any
real reason why the coronavirus should
should cause this there's no reason why
the coronavirus would lead to people
running out of toilet paper but it just
starts people go out they panic they
scoop it up and then other people say
well I need something so that and then
it's a self-generating it's mass
hysteria it's panic and we're watching
it play out right in front of our eyes
this is what it looks like
number four Camilla Harris endorsed Joe
Biden here she is here she is in what
seems to be a bunker recording an
endorsement video with it appears a
toaster so I just wanted you guys to
know because you've been supporting me
for so long and I just wanted you guys
to know I have decided that I am with
great enthusiasm I'm going to endorse
Joe Biden for President of the United
States I believe in gentlemen I really
believe in him and I have known him for
a long time one of the things that we
need right now is we need a leader who
really does care about the people and
who can therefore unify the people and I
believe Joe can do that I am supporting
Joe because I believe that he is a man
who has lived his life with great
dignity he is a public servant who has
always worked for the best of who we are
as a nation and we need that right now
there is so much at stake in this
election guys so join me in supporting
Joe and let's get this done that's got
to be the most begrudging endorsement
video I've ever seen and it's even worse
because she had to stipulate verbally
that she has enthusiasm I am with great
enthusiasm endorsing the guy I said
racist a lot of enthusiasm there like
remember she did in the debates not long
ago
tried to tie Joe Biden to segregationist
and she got very tearful about it that
was her one big moment where she was
tearfully accusing Joe Biden ABBA
friending segregationist and now she's
saying he's the guy for the job is his
dignity his great dignity the great
dignity of this man that I said a few
months ago was befriended segregations
the great dignity of this man finally
number five an article on study finds
org tells us here's just the headline it
says seniors who walk for 30 minutes
daily cut risk of death from any cause
your risk of death can be I read these
headlines and I immediately think maybe
I'm a maybe I'm a pessimistic a little
bit but I think you know I don't think
you can cut your risk of death from any
cause I think all of our our risk of
death from some cause or another is 100
percent we are 100 percent all going to
die absolutely again maybe pessimistic I
could be wrong about that but I think
that's so cutting your risk of death I
think we need to find another way of
phrasing that in the headline because
you see these headlines all the time
this or that thing supposedly will make
you less likely to die in fact I read
that in a headline I think was phrase
exactly like that recently less likely
to die if you do this or that I don't
know I'm skeptical I'm skeptical but
maybe I'll go for a walk it's worth
worth a shot let's go to your daily
cancellation today we're canceling the
folks in media who are claiming that
calling the coronavirus the Wuhan virus
is racist so just a couple of examples
here's David Gura of NBC making this
claim he says fYI calling Cove at 19 the
Wu ham virus is racist and then Chris
Hayes jumps into the action he says just
astoundingly gross to call it the Wu Han
virus and they're reacting specifically
to congressman Gosar who announced as I
said he's going into self quarantine
called it the Wu hen virus in the
process of announcing that and that's
where leftists and the media jumped in
and said how dare you call it the Wu hen
virus it's worth noting the media itself
was calling
the Wu Han virus when when this all
first started CNN use this phrase
consistently look at these headlines
they use this phrase consistently for
weeks now all the sudden the term has
gone out of fashion at least according
to our betters in the media but I wonder
if Wu Han virus is racist
then what about Spanish flu Stockholm
Syndrome West Nile virus Zika virus Lyme
disease German measles are all those
racists - and in any way there may be a
very good reason to call this the Wu Han
virus aside from the fact that that's
where it originated which is reason
enough and that's how we've named these
sorts of things in the past but take a
look at this tweet from China daily two
years ago May of 2018
okay I don't I don't this is not
conspiracy this is what this was this is
a tweet this is what it says and there
are some some pictures of people in
surgical masks and lab coats and it says
take a look at the largest virus Bank in
Asia
Wu Han Institute a viral viral biology
fire fire ecology virology virology
anyway Wu Han Institute of virology in
central and central China's Hubei
Province preserves more than 1,500
different strains of virus yeah I think
it might be 1499 now guys not 1,500 you
may you may have dropped one back there
accidentally I'm sure now I don't know
if there's any connection here all I
know is that apparently the largest
virus Bank in Asia was located in the
exact place where a viral pandemic
originated could be a coincidence I
suppose it could be or not but I guess
asking this question is racist can't ask
it can't talk about it it you know it's
it's even though there's a the largest
virus Bank in Asia is located at the
epicenter of this viral pandemic it's
still of course way more likely that the
whole thing started with with a bowl of
soup of bat soup started there you know
how did the bat get it who knows nobody
knows okay moving on to emails remember
you can subscribe
I urge you to go subscribe today so you
can submit questions to the mailbag
we've got let's see how much time we
have we've got one quick question from
Kate and then we're going to go to why
I'm wrong an email from somebody telling
me why I'm wrong about about in this
case about abortion this is from Kate
says my younger brother 17 has a fun
hobby of taking his Coonhound hunting
Friday nights with the dogs litter mates
and their owners my dad stepmom and I
were talking about this the other night
after he left come to find out one of
the other owners is a young girl his age
well naturally the topic turn to my
brother his lack of dating habits my dad
made a comment about how he's 17 it's
okay for him to date my stepmom suddenly
snaps well what's the difference between
him and his sister the running joke of
the family is that we daughters can't
date until we're married his defense
seemed to be along the lines of he
trusts my brother not to be the kind of
guy he's afraid of us daughter's getting
involved with I understood what he meant
but his explanation was a bit fumbled
and my stepmom is still annoyed even
saying that she was genuinely upset
about his stance if you got never good
when you get that from the wife I'm
genuinely upset I'm really upset about
this ever good never good if you got
through that and it made sense could you
possibly provide some arguments or
bullet points on why my dad is right or
possibly wrong on a side note my dad's
position on the subject has never
changed and I feel like that's the
reason why I didn't date until 21 and
married my first boyfriend who holds the
same position when it comes to our
daughter and son thanks for reading this
saga and I look forward to your advice
Kate first of all you know I appreciate
how you did the woman thing there and
provided narrative details that weren't
at all necessary to the point I'm not
it's not a criticism I just I I do enjoy
it that's my wife does the same thing
all women do if you want to tell a story
right you start the story much further
back in the timeline than you need to
and you work your way up the windy road
to get to the thing you want to discuss
my wife will sometimes begin the story
19 or 20 years before the events she
wants to describe her she'll bump into a
friend at
kroger and the you know the grocery
store and she'll want to tell me about
it but she'll start with the friends
infancy narrative and then she'll go
through leading up through the years and
decades their time in school and
everything and then eventually
culminating in this fateful encounter in
aisle 12 of the grocery store so here
you told me about your brother who
enjoys hunting with his [ __ ] hound and
then took me on a windy twisty trail
before finally getting to the question
of whether I think it makes sense for
parents to let their sons date earlier
than their daughters you're right that
that was a saga now this was a man
asking this question he would have just
dove right into the question that's it
quite one sentence question done but you
you set the stage for me and I
appreciate that and now I guess I'm sort
of doing the same thing that you did I'm
doing the same thing I accused you of
doing I've started with a preamble the
difference is I start everything I say
with a preamble which always involves my
opinions about things and then I get to
what I want to say women start with a
prologue so a sort of narrative verse
editorial okay do I think it makes sense
to be a bit more protective of our
daughters when it comes to dating yeah I
think it does and for the reason that
your dad gives of you know of we have to
protect our daughters potentially from
bad guys and and that's something we
have to do I also think we want to
protect our sons from certain girls we
can't lose sight of that there are bad
dudes out there they're also bad girls
and those girls can do a lot of
psychological and emotional damage
sometimes worse especially when you
think about the false accusations and
everything that are so common these days
but all the same when it comes to the
physical safety angle yes I think
there's a reason to be more protective
of our daughters that said while while I
believe that directionless dating is
pointless and ultimately bad that is
dating that does not have as its
intended end the contemplation of
marriage which doesn't mean of course as
you know that I'm saying that if you
date someone you must marry them but the
point is that if you date someone you
should at least be discerning marriage
and if you're not deserting marriage if
you've ruled the possibility of marriage
out to begin with there's really no
point of dating because you're doing
something that you know absolutely will
and in heartbreak there's no other
possibility and probably soon it will
end that way so you're not really
practicing marriage or practicing having
healthy relationships you're practicing
divorce you're practicing having
dysfunctional relationships and that's a
lot of what the dating scene is so I
think that's the case but at the same
time I also think it's not necessarily
wise for parents to tell their 17-year
olds that they can't date which it
sounds like that's what your daughter
your uh your daughter sounds like that's
what your dad did with his daughters we
told them that even at 17
I'm just context clues it seems like
that's what you're saying if that's the
case then um yeah I believe you have to
give kids some kind of freedom and
ability to make decisions before they
become adults because at 17 you're one
year away from legal adulthood and you
want to ease your kids into adulthood a
little bit and give them some freedoms
and and the ability to make choices
which doesn't mean you let your kids do
whatever they want it doesn't mean that
you you know you you have your kid
dating at the age of 11 I think that
there's probably some room in between
that and giving your kid no freedom at
all until they're adults so I think that
um there's room in between there for I
think a wiser and more prudent approach
you do have to worry about if you take
the ultra strict stance with your kids
and you say no dating eventually they're
gonna be adults and they're gonna be out
of your control and there's a good
chance that they're gonna run out and do
everything you didn't want them to do in
one repressed explosion because you are
far too strict and I say that as someone
who believes generally you know that
that's so-called at least what what what
our culture considers to be strict
parenting often is is the right approach
but it can go you can't go overboard
with it thank you for the question okay
finally why I'm wrong this is from Pat
says dear Matt you're wrong about
abortion you say an embryo is life so
what a virus is life
should we not kill viruses I know you'll
say human life is more valuable than
other kinds of life but you have to
defend why that would be the case anyway
the point is that the simple fact of a
thing
being life does not in and of itself
mean much of anything you must agree
with this dance since you were cheering
on capital punishment on Friday okay Pat
first of all I don't claim to be a
biologist but I think most biologists
will tell you that viruses are not life
actually they're not alive because they
lack some of the basic hallmarks of life
they're not self-sustaining they don't
grow they can't replicate replicate
without hijacking a living thing and or
an organism they can't do it on their
own so what are they is the question and
this is a live
pun intended debate among biologists and
scientists what is a virus exactly how
do you classify it
we like to classify things as people it
helps us sort of understand the world
around us not everything can be
classified so what is a virus is it dead
obviously not dead means that it was
living once and is no longer is a virus
in animals well it doesn't seem so
probably just doesn't seem like would
fit that qualification so it seems that
viruses are in some sort of gray area
between alive and not kind of like
biological robots or something your your
argument then is actually much weaker
than it could have been and so I'm going
to improve your argument for you and
then I'll address the better version of
your argument well you should have said
is that viruses are in a gray area
between alive and not alive
proving that such gray areas can exist
and therefore it's possible you would
argue that human embryos could occupy a
gray area they could be sort of
in-between and in which case you know
why wouldn't it be okay to kill them I
think that argument would have been much
stronger if you had offered it as for
that stronger argument now as I argue
against myself it's true that there
there might be a gray area but but the
organisms are rather the entities the
things that occupy that gray area are
there by their nature what I mean is the
gray area is not something that an
organism passes through on its way to
being alive viruses are always viruses
they aren't growing into living things
they aren't becoming anything
and that's one of the reasons why
scientists would say they're not alive
because they lack that capacity if they
were growing into a recognizable little
living thing then we would have there'd
be no ambiguity we would say they're
alive if if virus was a stage of
development for some organism there
would be no question that it is alive so
you know when it comes to us we're alive
you are a life Pat I'm sure you would
agree you currently are life you were
once in embryo just as you were once a
toddler these are stages of development
for you that you passed through so you
must have been living the whole time you
were a life the whole time this is if if
I were to as I've explained it many
times if I were to take you and go back
through your timeline in Reverse if I
were to hit reverse right on the remote
control of your life and follow you
backwards there would be an unbroken
chain of unis connecting the you of
today to the you that was in the womb I
mean it's you the whole time right and
therefore you were living the whole time
as for human life being more valuable
than other kinds of life well you
actually agree with me on that whether
you pretend to or not and I know that
you agree with me I am yes I'm going to
read your mind and say that you
absolutely agree with me on that and I
know you do because if you saw someone
step on an ant or if you step on an ant
yourself as I'm sure you have you do not
react the same way as you would if you
saw someone shoot another person or if
you saw someone run over a child in
their car okay you would react to the
lad or much much stronger than you do
react to the former just like you're
driving down the road you see a dead
deer dead raccoon on the side of the
road I'm assuming you don't pull over
and weep every time you see that you
don't even think about it you just you
just keep along your way now if you were
driving along you saw a dead person
on the side of the road that's going to
be something that you remember and
you're gonna react to that emotionally
why is that so I think what that
establishes is that you do see a
difference whether you for whether you
acknowledge it or not the question that
is why do you see the difference
why is human life more valuable you can
approach that question from two
perspectives one if you believe in God
in a judeo-christian God at least you
say that humans were created in the
image of God we are divine image bearers
and we have rational souls and this
gives us a certain value in dignity the
other creatures lack we were also given
a dominion over over those over those
other animals now if you don't so it's
pretty simple from from a god-fearing
perspective if you don't believe in God
even then um humans are still more
valuable simply because we're the most
evolved were at the top of the food
chain that makes us better than
everything beneath us all the organisms
beneath us we're at the top we're
superior dog-eat-dog right that's the
Darwinian perspective and so we're still
more valuable in that case now if if the
unless you're going to approach this
from a totally nihilistic perspective
and say existence has no meaning nothing
has any meaning does nothing doesn't
matter you know whether the entire earth
exists or gets sucked into a black hole
makes no difference whatsoever if that's
how you're approaching it then then sure
fine I guess from that perspective
there's no way to see anything wrong
with abortion but there's also there's
also no reason to keep living there's no
reason to care about anything there's no
reason to do anything there's no reason
to have any priorities whatsoever right
given the fact that you've emailed me I
assume you do care about some things
which means you don't you don't have
that fully nihilistic perspective but
actually all of this being said the fact
that we are superior to other organisms
doesn't give us the right to treat those
other organisms however we want we
should still treat them with respect and
dignity in fact even the ant I would say
even with an ants now if somebody steps
on an ant I'm not gonna cry over but
over it neither were you but you
shouldn't just on purpose for no reason
step on an ant I think if there's an
infestation in your home you can kill
them for that reason but you're walking
down the sidewalk you see an ant you
know it's one thing if you accident but
are you gonna go out of your way just
step on the ant for no reason I would
say that's wrong should do that I don't
think it's a serious moral you know
moral evil but it's it's it's a wrong
thing to do you because you are
destroying life for no reason at all
just for entertainment I guess and
that's wrong but when we get to the
higher animals you know puppies and
things like that well I think we all
would be opposed to dismember incurring
the skull of a kitten and it would
indeed be illegal to do those things
because our law treats the offspring of
dogs and cats with greater respect than
it treats human offspring and and I hope
we can both agree that that is
definitely not justified but that's the
way our law works and it's inevitable as
long as abortion is legal the it's
inevitable that there's going to be a
stage of human development where the
people in that stage have less legal
protection than dogs and cats and
squirrels and I mean any and sea turtles
and really any other almost any other
life form you can think of and that's um
pretty horrific I hope you would agree
we will leave it there thank you for the
email Pat everybody have a great night
and remember I will be at University of
Maryland tonight at 7 o'clock talking
about the left's war on reality hope to
see you there Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle well
tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we'll
get a whole lot of that and much more
see you there